for that well an iconic Las Vegas home
could be at the edge of being demolished
thank you so much for joining us here at
4 30 I'm Christian casabis and I'm
Kirsten Joyce the Heartland Mansion also
known as Mansion 54 located east of the
Arts District scheduled to be taken down
after a new owner bought the property
fire trucks coming and and people in the
yards and trash and and sawing and
people on the roof Mia palancar still
can't believe this iconic property
across from her home on 6th and park
Paseo could soon disappear huge amount
of history for starting from the 40s
Elvis stayed here Michael Jackson a lot
of great bands played here I heard Frank
Sinatra it was beautiful inside at one
time according to the Nevada film
commission website the Heartland Mansion
was built in the 1940s began as two
separate properties but in the 70s it
was combined into one Grammy gospel
singer Tony Hart purchased the home in
the 80s and the family renovated it with
a unique look it was actually gorgeous
inside it had a swimming pool lots of
gold artifacts the movie Casino and
CeeLo greens All I Need Is Love music
video with the Muppets were just a
sample of projects filmed inside the
property over the years
but now that will soon be part of the
past both City and fire officials
telling eight news now plans to demolish
the property are underway County records
show the home was sold May of this year
for four million dollars to Lanny Dean
love owner of the adult Superstores
we're all concerned what exactly you're
going to put there we certainly don't
want to high rise
well we reached out to the new property
owner but we did not hear back now fire
officials say until the demolition
happens fire Crews will be using the
property for safety drills